Lo que haremos en este video será multiplicar
los números 352 y 481, llegaremos al resultado
de dos formas distintas, sin embargo, al final te
darás cuenta de que las ideas importantes son las
mismas. Lo primero que quiero que notes es que
352 lo podemos ver como 300 + 50 + 2, o déjame
escribirlo así: es 2 + 50 + 300; si sumas estos
tres números juntos obtienes 352. La misma idea
para 481, al 481 lo podemos ver como cuatro veces
100 o 400 + 8 veces 10 u 80 + 1, y 400, es decir,
cuatro veces 10 + 80, que es lo mismo que 8 veces
10 + 1. Seguramente estás familiarizado con esta
forma de escribir los números y acomodarlos en
esta cuadrícula. Esencialmente vamos a aplicar
la propiedad distributiva, tomaremos el 2 y
lo multiplicaremos por 400, por 80 y por 1.
Así que me permíteme dibujar la cuadrícula para
que todo sea más claro. Bien, de modo que vamos
a multiplicar al 2 x 400 + 80 + 1, y entonces
me queda que 2 x 400, bueno, eso es 800, 2 x 80
eso es 160, 2 x 1 es 2. Hagamos lo mismo para el
50: 50 x 400, bueno 5 x 4 es 20, entonces es 20
y tres ceros más, 1, 2, 3, 20,000. Ahora, 50 x 80,
bueno, 5 x 8 es 40 más dos ceros, ok, uno, dos, me
queda 4,000, y luego 50 x 1 que es 50. Bien,
ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo para el 300, vamos
a distribuirlo por la suma de estos tres: 300 x
400, bueno, 3 x 4 es 12 y cuatro ceros, 1, 2, 3,
4, 120,000, perfecto. 300 x 80, bueno, 3 x 8
es 24 y tres ceros, por lo tanto es 24,000,
y 300 x 1, bueno, eso es 300. De lujo. Ahora hay
que sumar todos estos números, así que sumaremos
primero esta fila. Si sumo 800 + 160 + 2, bueno,
eso me da 962. Bien, aquí tengo, bueno, 24,050,
observa, y por acá abajo tengo 144,300: 120,000
+ 24,000 + 300, 144,300. Y ahora, para obtener el
resultado final, simplemente hay que sumar estas
tres cantidades, pero antes de sumarlas quiero
ver otra forma de multiplicar estos dos números.
A veces a este segundo algoritmo que voy a aplicar
justo ahorita se le conoce con el nombre de
algoritmo estándar. La forma de hacerlo es tomar
al 481 y multiplicarlo por el 352. En el algoritmo
estándar lo que hacemos es tomar este 2 que está
en las unidades y lo multiplicamos por 481, y
dice: 2 x 1 es 2, 2 x 8 es 16, así que ponemos
el 6 y llevamos 1. Aunque realmente lo que estamos
haciendo es reagrupando este 1 en las centenas, es
10 veces 10, que es 100. Y luego 2 x 4 que es 8,
que realmente es 800, más lo que 1 que llevábamos,
9, que en realidad es 900. Y creo que ya estás
viendo un patrón por aquí. Este 962 es el mismo
que este 962, ¿por qué? Bueno, porque realmente lo
que hicimos fue multiplicar el 2 x 1, el 2 x 80 y
el 2 x 400, lo mismo que hicimos aquí, y después
lo sumamos: 962. Esto es lo que realmente hace el
algoritmo estándar. Ahora podemos movernos al 5,
pero realmente este 5 es cinco veces 10, y es por
ello que ponemos un 0 aquí abajo en el algoritmo
estándar, antes de hacer toda la multiplicación
con el 5, ¿recuerdas? Y dice: 5 x 1 es 5, 5 x 8
es 40, así que ponemos el 0 y reagrupamos el 4,
5 x 4 es 20, más 4 es 24. Observa: 24,050, lo
mismo que teníamos aquí. Suena lógico porque
estamos tomando el 50 y lo estamos multiplicando
por 481, fue lo mismo que hicimos a la izquierda.
Ya puedes imaginar qué va a pasar cuando tomas
este 3 y lo multiplicas por 481, realmente lo
que haces es multiplicar 300 x 481, por lo que en
el algoritmo estándar, como estamos multiplicando
por 300, ponemos dos ceros al principio. Y, bueno,
cuando digo algoritmo me refiero a un método para
resolver algo. Si multiplicamos 3 x 1 es 3, 3 x
8 es 24, así que pongo el 4 y llevo 2, 3 x 4 es
12 + 2 es 14. Observa: 144,300. Una vez aquí, en
el algoritmo estándar sumamos estas cantidades,
por lo tanto, sumaremos todo y me queda 2 + 0 +
0, bueno, eso es 2, y después tengo 6 + 5 es 11,
llevamos 1, 1 + 9 + 3 es 13, ponemos el 3 y
llevamos 1, 1 + 4 + 4 eso es 9, 2 + 4 es 6 y
bajo el 1. Ya está, el resultado es 169,312.
Y cuando aprendes el algoritmo estándar parece
que todo sale por arte de magia. Pero ahora sabes
lo que realmente estás haciendo, lo que realmente
haces es ir a cada uno de estos lugares y los
distribuyes, es decir, lo multiplicas por 400,
por 80 y por 1, y los sumas, después tomas
el siguiente número, que realmente es 50,
y lo multiplicas por 400 + 80 + 1, y después
300 y lo multiplicas por 400 + 80 + 1,
de la misma manera como lo hicimos aquí. Eso
es todo por este video; hasta la próxima.